president biden accuses facebook of
killing people by allowing too much free
speech
and taxpayer-funded npr targets the
daily wire for destruction i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment and much news there is first
let us remind you that the federal
government is about to inflate the
currency away this is the thing that is
going to happen over the course of time
but it doesn't mean you should be
diversified into assets
other than the united states dollar and
one of the ways that you do this is by
protecting yourself with investment
in precious metals now is the time to
declare your independence for your
savings cut your ties to the us dollar
invest in gold and silver
with birch gold group if you haven't
reached out to birch gold yet to
diversify part of your ira or 401k
into a precious metals ira do it today
text ben
247 4747 get a free information kit on
protecting your savings with gold i buy
my gold from birch gold we've got an a
plus rating with the better business
bureau countless five star reviews over
ten thousand happy customers
talk to them have them help you
safeguard your investments text ben
to 47 47 47 to claim your free
information kit and speak with a
precious metals expert on holding gold
and silver in a tax sheltered account
again text ben into 47 47 47 to get
started protect your savings today
if you're a responsible investor you
know that relying on the united states
at dollar
while this administration blows it out
is a bad idea instead
invest a little bit into gold and silver
by texting ben's 47-47-47 getting
started with my friends over
at birch gold alright so we are now in
the midst of a
great move from the federal government
led by the white house aided and abetted
and fostered
by the establishment media to shut down
your access to information you want to
see
it is that simple what we are watching
right now is an overt i mean it's
right there in the public eye it's an
overt collusion between the
establishment media
which wishes to re-establish its
monopoly over informational
dissemination
between the media and the democratic
party which would like you to only see
the crap that the mainstream media is
often pushing and social media
whom both of the aforementioned parties
are now going to push
into shutting down your access to
information so to understand how this
works
you have to sort of understand briefly
the history of how informational
dissemination
has happened in the united states so if
you go all the way back
the way people used to get their
information at the very beginning of the
republic was a bunch of different
partisan papers and people would
subscribe to them
pick them up they were largely local and
they were pretty openly partisan
there is a reason why for example the
arizona republic was sort of a
republican paper
there's a reason why the arkansas
democrat gazette was the arkansas
democrat gazette right the fact is that
you would have all these newspapers
and they would have their various
partisan spins and that's just the way
that it was
then in the 1920s there was this move to
sort of regularize journalism
and the idea here is that journalism was
a process right you had to have double
sourcing for example
you had to make sure that every factual
claim that you made
was objectively verifiable and that's
not a bad thing but it led to the rise
of a professional so-called journalist
class
which would be fine if they were
actually just professionals following a
process the way that scientists are
supposed to follow the scientific
process instead
what this led to was the rise of a cadre
of self-described journalists who were
supposedly better at this
than anybody else and they stopped doing
journalism they went back to being
partisans but they just didn't tell you
and so for years for decades in the
united states there as the
media began to nationalize as the means
of transportation became better and the
means of communication became better
there was a new mode of informational
distribution
and it was like tv there are only three
networks abc nbc cbs that was it and
everybody got their news at night from
these three networks
as far as major newspapers there were
only a few that were nationally
disseminated it's like the new york
times the wall street journal the
washington post that was pretty much it
and so everybody got their information
from these very narrow bandwidths
of information right these very narrow
means of distribution
then came the internet and it exploded
all this the internet basically allowed
anybody to put up news it was almost a
reversion
to the origins of the republic it wasn't
local it was national but
you could go to a wide variety of
websites you could check
a wide variety of perspectives and there
was this really
rich sort of interplay between how
people were writing
is in the very early days of the
internet then there was the rise of
social media and social media
as is so often the case was supposed to
facilitate all of this and now
has put it in danger social media was
supposed to give you
a one-stop shop for doing all of this
instead of you having to
bookmark 10 pages if you're older than
about 18 years old you know that this is
how people used to do things right you'd
have a list of bookmarks
on the side of your web browser and then
every morning you would check like the
new york times
and the jerusalem post you checked the
washington post and you would check
national review you'd be able to check
all of these things right
via the book but via the bookmarks then
facebook because it aggregated so many
eyeballs because so many people were
using facebook for example
they started providing a news feed and
the news feed was supposed to
basically make bookmarks obsolete right
when was the last time you used a
bookmark
right nobody uses bookmarks on the
internet anymore because instead they
have this
curated list of things that they read
and that curated list is curated
by social media it's curated by facebook
it's curated by for example twitter by
your by your twitter feed
okay so the idea here was that it was
supposed to be easier for you to access
all the information you wanted to see
the problem was that whereas before
because you were the person who's
clicking on all the bookmarks you were
in control of the stuff that you were
seeing
having handed control that over to
facebook or to twitter
for purposes of basically ease right you
didn't want to click 10 buttons and said
you click one and then you just watch
the scroll
now the democrats and the media have
seen
that as all information and
informational distribution is
re-narrowed
into these these narrow bandwidths
instead of everybody getting their news
from a wide variety of sources now you
get your news quote unquote from
facebook
and then you click through right once
they saw that everybody had to go
through facebook they realized
they could re-establish the monopoly all
they would have to do
is simply say to facebook that facebook
was guilty of deep and abiding sin if
they allowed you to see the information
you wanted to see twitter
needed to suppress information that you
were not supposed to see
it was very important that if you liked
information too much that the mainstream
media and the democrats didn't like
that these social media platforms
instead of easing your ability to see
information restrict your ability to see
information
so the entire rationale for the social
medias
these social media networks being in the
news business in the first place got
reversed
instead of them making it easier for you
to access information democrats in the
media seeing that you were now using
them almost universally
they decided this is a great way of
ensuring
that you don't see information this is a
great way of purging these particular
outlets
of the information restricting your
ability to see them
shadow banning preventing advertising
they could re-establish their
traditional monopoly by using
these giant companies they're going to
leverage these giant companies into
doing what they wanted and so you have
this bizarre spectacle of the media who
are supposed to be
the great defenders of a free press i've
never called for cnn to lose its license
i have never called for the new york
times's distribution on facebook to be
reduced because
i don't care it's not my job but these
other outlets will do that cnn will do
that about fox news the new york times
will do that about the daily wire npr
will do that about the delaware as we'll
see
the idea from these folks is only they
should be giving you information
and if information is obtained from any
place else
then facebook has done something deeply
wrong and they will be the judges of
what is good information and what is not
good information
and the biden administration is very
into this this is authority
authoritarian nonsense
it is authoritarian i have a book coming
out next week called the authoritarian
moment it is all about this this is
i mean the timing couldn't be better it
is all about this it is about the
attempt by
the media and the democratic party using
social media
to abort your ability to see the
information that you want to see
in authoritarian fashion it is ugly and
you should be worried about it whether
you're on the right or on the left or in
the center should be worried about it
regardless because guess what
this game goes both ways if you're a
republican in office
we're saying that facebook should
restrict information from the new york
times
the media would be going ape bleep but
because they are because the media are
complicit in this now the media are the
greatest
weapon against free speech happening in
the country right now
the democratic party are fully
participatory in this because
they must have utopia and they will do
it at the price of your ability to
access information
it is hideous we'll get to more of this
in just one second because we can see it
in practice
and it is very clear now first let us
talk about being a responsible human
being so you need the insurance that you
need
you need life insurance if you're a
responsible person you also need home
and auto insurance
by law if you want to drive around you
need auto insurance but you're probably
not getting the best price
on any of this stuff policy genius makes
it easy to compare home and auto
insurance in one place
they can help you find home and auto
coverage similar to what you have now
but at a lower price
they've saved customers an average of 1
250 per year
over what they were paying for home and
auto insurance their team will handle
the paperwork to set up your new policy
or switch over your current one
getting started is super simple first
head on over to policygenius.com
shapiro home and answer a few quick
questions about yourself and your
property
then policy genius takes it from there
they'll compare rates from america's top
insurers from progressive to allstate to
find your lowest quotes the policy
genius team can look for ways to save
you more
including bundling your home and auto
policies if they find a better rate than
what you're paying now they will switch
you over
for free their top-notch service has
earned policy genius thousands of
five-star reviews across trustpilot
and google head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro home
to get started right now policy genius
when it comes to insurance it's nice
and very important to get it right okay
so once again to understand the origins
of the new anti-social media push the
attempt to use social media
as a way of restricting informational
flow
you have to understand there was a
tremendous reversal that happened with
regard to left-wing views of social
media directly after 2016. so when trump
won in 2016
the social media before that was
considered this godsend you'll recall
that there are articles in 2012 about
the brilliant use of social media
by the obama administration and the and
the obama team in the 2012 election what
an amazing job they had done
in using social media to reach the
people they wanted to reach and facebook
was a tool for this you'll remember
facebook was a tool
in the arab spring facebook was a way
for oppressed and suppressed people all
over the world to get out their message
then
trump won and suddenly the democrats
deeply in need
of some sort of narrative to explain
away trump's win instead of just saying
hillary clinton was a horrific candidate
which is why she lost
instead of doing that the media and the
democrats latched on to a narrative the
narrative was
facebook twitter your social media
brethren
all of these giant companies they were
responsible and the re the way they were
responsible is they had not
properly policed themselves for things
like russian disinformation
right russian disinformation this stuff
was super dangerous now here is the
thing
the russians did try to intervene in the
2016 election
their actual activity on facebook if you
read into the senate report
does not even chart in terms of
important things that happened with
regard to social media in 2016.
like the actual amount of attention
their posts were getting was actually
low if you know the metrics but
that doesn't matter the narrative had
been set and the narrative was that
these
media these social media outlets were
being used as props
by cutouts essentially from foreign
countries
then something subtle happened all of
these informational outlets
members the media the democrats they
shifted the argument from its russian
disinformation
meaning actual action prop put out by a
foreign government in order to pervert
an american election
which is actually dangerous and which
should be prevented on social media they
moved from that to
from disinformation to they just
switched from letter misinformation
misinformation was anything democrats
didn't like now
social media had to step in and prevent
misinformation not disinformation right
disinformation is an actual term
that is used in the intelligence
community to talk about a foreign
government
subsidizing agitrop misinformation can
mean anything
misinformation can mean the hunter biden
story a month before the election
misinformation
can mean that you don't think anthony
fauci did a good job during this
pandemic
misinformation can be nearly anything so
long as the media call it misinformation
and then call on the federal government
to pressure facebook
into preventing its dissemination you
can basically
leverage facebook into doing whatever
you want right the shift from
disinformation to misinformation is
deeply important
at the beginning the social media tech
bros they were kind of resistant to this
they said yeah we have to do a better
job with russian disinformation but the
reality is that we
are platforms right and as platforms it
is not our job
to go around trying to discern true from
false
in a variety of public sect we're
literally a platform in the same way
that like your phone line is a platform
right when you get on your phone line
and you tell your wife that you're
you'll remember everything at the
grocery store and then you don't
that does not make the phone line
responsible for you saying something
untrue to your wife
facebook is not responsible i mean
legally or morally they are not
responsible for people saying things
that are untrue and certainly they're
not responsible for a subjective claim
that some people think is true and some
people think is false
and and at the beginning facebook kind
of acknowledged this right many of
social media
heads would say yeah we're not
responsible for that freedom of speech
requires
that we allow opinions that we may not
like and allow dissemination of
information
that you may think is false but is
actually arguable and we need to have
conversations over
and then over time as the democrats
pressed you started to see social media
react to the to the press they started
to react to this this started last year
particularly during the pandemic when
social media started cracking down on
people
who suggested for example that the
chinese lab leak
theory was correct they started saying
you can't disseminate that that's false
you can't put that out there
they started saying about covet that if
you have if you put out any material on
covid if you say for example
that lockdowns have not been
particularly effective which they have
not been by all available scientific
data if you say that
that could be a serious problem you
might get a strike from youtube you
might have facebook restrict your
informational dissemination
if you say on some platforms that a man
and his man and a woman is a woman
now all of a sudden you could see social
media crack down on you
i know people there's a feminist name
megan murphy for example who was kicked
off twitter for the great sin
of saying that a man was a man and a
woman was a woman he started to see
the shift from disinformation to
misinformation actually activated inside
social media
and now it's coming to a head now it's
coming to a head because joe biden
the white house the media believe that
this is their shot to consolidate power
forever they believe that their shot at
consolidating power requires
a crackdown on informational
dissemination the lever that they will
use
is they will say that social media are
not just bad
they're not just providing you a space
to put out things that are false they
are killing people right this is always
the democrat and media excuse for
cracking down on your freedoms
is that you're killing people right this
is why the the far left
has decided that words are violence and
speech is violence
we have to stop it if we don't stop it
people will die
and if people will die then we must use
all the
weapons at our disposal to prevent that
and that may include
suppression of some of your freedoms and
it will certainly include pressuring
these social media companies into
shutting down the flow of information
this is the exact argument that joe
biden is now making with regard to covid
it is despicable and it is authoritarian
and is garbage
again i'm gonna pitch my book the
authoritarian moment shameless plug
right there because it is all about this
how the left is weaponizing america's
institutions if you want the country to
fall apart
if you want us not to be able to have
conversations this is precisely the way
to do it but this is not about having a
conversation
this is about shutting down a
conversation from people who are very
much afraid
you might get your information from a
place they do not approve they don't
just want to be quote unquote
journalistic gatekeepers who prevent
untruth they want to be gatekeepers of
content who prevent you from seeing
anything
you don't like period end of story this
is their goal
i'll explain more in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that
if you are hiring at your company
sometimes it can be rough to find
the right people you need zip recruiter
if you're a business owner who's hiring
you'll probably face a lot of challenges
when it comes to finding the right
person for your role especially right
now it's difficult out there
for an employer seeking a great
workforce that's why a hiring can feel
like trying to find a needle in a
haystack sure
you could post your job to some job
board but then all you can do is hope
the right person comes along
that's why you should try ziprecruiter
for free at ziprecruiter.com
dailywire when you post a job on zip
recruiter gets sent out to over 100 top
job sites with just one click men
zip recruiters matching technology finds
people with the right skills and
experience for your job and actively
invites them to apply
in fact zip recruiter is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the very first day
it's no wonder over 2.3 million
businesses have come to zip recruiter
for their hiring needs so
while other companies overwhelm you with
way too many options zip recruiter finds
you what you're looking for the needle
in the haystack right now
you can try zip recruiter for free at
this web address ziprecruiter.com
dailywire once again remember
ziprecruiter.com
zip recruiter is indeed the smartest way
to hire okay so
the crackdown on social media requires
some sort of hook the hook here
is you're killing people social media is
killing people so joe biden
supposed moderate supposed unifying
force in america supposed respecter
of traditional american rights on friday
he said one of the more egregious things
that i've heard president say in quite a
long time that includes president trump
joe biden gets out there and he says
that facebook is responsible
for killing people facebook what's your
message to platforms like facebook
they're killing people i mean it really
look the only pandemics we have is among
the unvaccinated
and that's and they're killing people
okay facebook is a platform facebook is
not killing people that's an absurd
contention for the president of the
united states
to say that about a platform for
dissemination of information is patently
insane it's the equivalent of saying
that the phone line is killing people
because you know sometimes people make
drug deals on phone lines and then
somebody brings the drugs over and
somebody od's
that is a t's fault it's an insane
contention it's wild and it's ridiculous
and it's crazy and the reason he's
saying it is because he would like to
suppress
your ability to access information that
you want
now none of this is a defense of people
who actually put out false information
right two things can be true at once one
it is not facebook's job to determine
what is shaded information and what is
debatable information and what joe biden
thinks is true as we'll determine in a
second
it turns out that half the crap that
democrats have said over the past year
about this pandemic is not true like
overtly not true
and that it turns out that vaccine
hesitancy is in large part due to the
vacillating nature
of the democratic response and the biden
administration response to this virus
and to the vaccines
but and by the way you're not going to
get more people to vaccinate if you tell
them explicitly if you're explicitly
saying
that you are not allowed to see debated
information
and make up your own mind but instead
joe biden's going to tell you what to do
you think more people are going to
vaccinate because of that truly you
think that's going to be an effective
tactic given the fact that people don't
trust joe biden on this anyway and
people certainly don't trust the
establishment media
when he says that facebook is killing
people what he means is that there are
people
who put out bad information about
vaccines on facebook
guess what people put out bad
information about say calling people jim
crow racist for opposing voter id
on facebook should that be suppressed as
well this is not facebook's job
if you wish people to believe the truth
about vaccines make the argument
this show i personally we're about as
pro-vaccine as it is possible
to be i was calling on everybody to get
the vaccine before joe biden was
i was saying that it was the pathway to
unmasking well before the biden
administration was
okay so this is not about pro versus
anti-vaxxing
the the notion that joe biden gets to
dictate to facebook what information
is put on the platform is despicable
he's the one he's the president of the
united states there's an amendment to
the constitution the very first one
and it says that freedom of the press
and freedom of speech are guaranteed it
is not
the job of the federal government to
determine whether quote-unquote false or
true information is put out on private
platforms that were literally designed
to be
again platforms hey by the way wouldn't
you
imagine he wasn't saying this about
about
the uh about facebook imagine you were
saying this about the new york times
because when i'm old enough to remember
because i'm more than two years old
when donald trump was saying that the
new york times was fake news and
everybody in the media
said that this is a threat to freedom of
the press he didn't even say they should
be suppressed
he didn't say that they should be put
out of business
if he did it was because donald trump
said wild stuff all the time nobody took
that seriously but if you say this about
social media
in the democratic party and in the media
you are considered good
it is an act of good right shutting down
facebook
is is apparently of no threat at all you
know why because the media are rooting
for facebook to just become the
disseminators of the new york times and
the washington post
and the and abc news and nbc and cbs
that is what they're looking for they're
looking for a re-establishment of the
media monopoly on the back of the lie
that the real reason for lack of
vaccinations is because of facebook
okay there are people who are
responsible for putting out bad
information and those people
are wrong and they are doing something
bad it is not facebook's job
to be the giant god that sits above all
informational distribution
and does these things at the behest of
the biden administration which by the
way has lied about a thousand times
on on issues related to the vaccine and
vacillated about a thousand times on
issues related to the vaccine from
whether schools should be reopening
to how vaccines should be handed out on
the basis of quote unquote equity
to whether you can unmask after you're
vaccinated that's just stuff that's
happened in the last like four months
hey but this is the push right so jen
saki doubles down on this she says
that people should be banned from all
social media for spreading
misinformation remember
misinformation not russian
disinformation
misinformation and she's not specific
about what misinformation constitutes
this is where things get messy because
if you made the argument that somebody
put out a statement let's say the
statement said
vaccines are utterly ineffective they do
nothing right that is a false statement
there are terms of service that prevent
you from doing that on most of these
major media
social media outlets but if you say for
example
that there are still open questions with
regard to the use of vaccines in
children
which there most certainly are if you
say that
is that misinformation it depends on the
white house's perspective that day if
they wish to push vaccines to children
then the answer is sure that's
misinformation that should be curbed
and if they don't then presumably that
gets to live if you've got the white
house dictating what people can and
cannot see that is a violation of the
first amendment even if they are
leveraging private companies into doing
it
here is jin saki trying to trying to
push this
steps that we have um you know that
could be constructive for the public
health
uh of the country are uh providing
uh for for facebook or other platforms
to measure and publicly share the impact
of misinformation on their platform
and the audience it's reaching uh also
with the public with all of you
to create robust enforcement strategies
that bridge their properties and provide
transparency about rules you shouldn't
be banned from one platform
and not others if you affor
providing misinformation out there
so you should be on from all does this
sound like a centralization of power
over freedom of dissemination of
information to you and do you trust
these people
to decide what constitutes
misinformation according to these people
the steele dossier was not
misinformation even though it actually
probably was russian disinformation
it was not misinformation steele dossier
but the new york post printing
details about hunter biden's laptop was
misinformation according to these so you
trust them
to determine what information you can
see this is a scary scary thing that
they are pushing and it is the media who
are complicit in it the media is worse
than the government here
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first let us talk about a simple
fact
no you've got medical problems you
should get the medical problem solved or
you shouldn't sit around and wait for
the medical problem to solve itself
it's very rare that it happens
particularly when you've got a life
affecting problem like erectile
dysfunction with roman you get a free
online evaluation and
ongoing care for ed all from the comfort
and privacy of your home
a us licensed health care professional
will work with you to find the best
treatment plan if medication is
appropriate it ships you free
with two day shipping the whole process
is straightforward and discreet getting
started is simple just go to
getroman.com
ben complete an online visit today take
care of your ed without leaving your
home
complete an online visit today to
connect with a healthcare professional
and get it taken care of
go to getroman.com right now you'll get
15 bucks off your very first month
it's really time to take care of your ed
remember get started today you'll save
on your first order of ed treatment
again medical issues it can really wreck
your life
why not just go get them solved and do
it quickly and discreetly and
inexpensively at getroman.com
you'll get 15 bucks off your first month
of coverage right now g-e-t-r-o-m-a-n
dot com
ben right now alrighty so it is not
merely that the government
is now actively pushing social media to
restrict the flow of information
do you do you trust them to do this even
if you agree with them on vaccines do
you trust them to do this broadly
and do you think they're going to
restrict this to vaccines as you'll see
the answer here is pretty
obviously no it's the media too and this
is where
the pathetic self-interest of media
members
the pathetic ridiculous anger at the
fact that people don't want to watch cnn
but do want to watch shows like this one
get over yourselves seriously get over
yourselves
these these ridiculous jackass members
of the new york times editorial board
these ridiculous people
who work for msnbc and cnn and who
suggest that it should be the job of
government to sit
over social media and to tell social
media when to take down information
and not to take down information how are
you not threatened by this are you so
short-sighted that you don't see how
this will be used against you eventually
and if you cross the government the
government will cross you
do you not see that once you set up this
iron matrix
between the between the mainstream media
or establishment media
and the democratic party and social
media to suppress information don't you
see how that could flip
very easily the other way how if a
republican gets elected president
and then you've got right-wing media
sources who say that there is
disinformation on the platforms and they
should use all aspects of power to
suppress that quote-unquote
disinformation or misinformation
don't you see how that can be used
against you but you don't care you don't
care because you believe that this is
your tool for forever power
you believe and you're correct at cnn
your ratings are gone
and so it is your job to make sure that
nobody else
is able to disseminate information you
over at the new york times yes you've
increased your subscriptions because you
kept saying trump over and over and over
again for several years now
but you guys are afraid that online
platforms like mine are coming after you
and so you're very happy
to watch facebook quote unquote suppress
information even though
you're talking about suppressing
information that has nothing to do
with falsity we'll see this in just one
second
okay the sanguinity the perfect
comfortableness
of members of the media pushing
suppression of information
boggles the mind the founders never
would have conceived of this
if the founders had known that the
greatest expositors of suppression
of freedom of information would be
members of the press it would have blown
their minds
it would have blown their minds it it
really is
an amazing thing the founders they got
so many things right but there are a few
things that they got wrong
one is they thought for example members
of congress would be so ambitious
to keep their own power they would never
cede power to the executive branch
wrong members of congress decided long
ago that they were their job was going
to be to vote on omnibus packages kick
everything over to the executive branch
and avoid culpability and responsibility
to their own citizens back home
right so that was a mistake the founders
thought that ambition would be the real
problem
it turns out cowardice was the real
problem when it comes to the press the
founders felt
that when it came to freedom of the
press the threat would come from
government they didn't think the
threat was going to come from inside the
house working with the government they
felt
that journalists would at least have
enough temerity
to stand up for fellow members of the
press that if members of the press were
being targeted by an administration
that the the other members of the press
would stand up and say no
but they they didn't believe presumably
that the members of the press would be
actively cheerleading the suppression of
information via social media but that's
exactly what's happening right now
there's an entire cnn panel yesterday in
which the panel was uh panelists were
arguing on cnn
right again an establishment media news
network
they were arguing that facebook and
social media are polluting
the informational environment polluting
it again
facebook is not the polluter facebook is
the river if there are people who are
polluting that environment
as on facebook's fault any more than
it's the river's fault if somebody puts
out bad information
and if you want to target misinformation
then target the source of the
misinformation
but this notion that the river itself is
responsible for the pollution is nuts
doesn't matter people on cnn were
pushing this
i actually took the time to read uh dr
vivek murthy's
report today the surgeon general and i
think it will stand up the way the
surgeon general's report in 1962 did
about pollution
being bad for our health in 1964 the
surgeon general issued a report about
how smoking
is bad for our health well facebook is
bad for our health they're polluting the
information
environment and i'm glad that the the
white house is calling by that great
many conservatives agree with this
they're always
uh complaining about big tech but this
is
critically important no conservatives do
not agree
with the critique that public colleges
made their criticism of big tech is that
big tech has become a tool of the
establishment media and the government
because you're saying this sort of stuff
actively right mika brzezinski and
johnny deutsch did the same routine
facebook has blood on its hand again the
goal here
is to the there's a reason why they are
directing most of their fire
not at the people they actually hate
right they're not directing most of
their fire
at say daily wire or at fox news
right first of all they can't with
regard to daily wire and vaccine issues
because we are very pro vaccine
generally
over at the daily wire but even if we
weren't
right they're not directing their fire
there they are directing their fire
where they think it is most likely to be
responded to
they're directing their pressure
campaign at the people most likely to
collapse namely
the corporate heads of places like
facebook who tend to be
somewhat sympathetic to the left-wing
position and also are very much afraid
of regulation
by them they're not it's amazing right
they're not directing their fire at the
people with whom they actually disagree
they're directing their fire at people
they know they can control
that's the reason they're attacking
facebook that's the reason that they're
attacking social media
because if they can just use facebook as
their tool then they can strangle
the alternative media in the crib that's
the goal amika brzezinski and johnny
deutch doing just that yesterday
how dare they still allow this to happen
so you want one simple thing i don't
care you're putting up their response
i don't care what their response is they
can do more they are
in the trillions as far as the net
network and shame on them they have
blood on their hands i want to say it
again
specifically call out two people mark
zuckerberg sheryl sandberg
you run the company if i ran that
company if i was mark zuckerberg and i'm
worth 100 billion dollars
i don't know i might go into my pocket a
little bit if i can save some life shame
on you
i stand with you on that donnie
of course you do of course you do
because you guys are partisan democrats
and your goal is to pressure facebook
into suppressing not just information
about covid but any information you
don't like so facebook by the way put
out a tone
it's amazing this is happening right now
i mean we have information you remember
dr foutre's emails
in those emails was an email from mark
zuckerberg to dr fauci specifically
asking him
how they could work together to suppress
what they called
misinformation on kovid so facebook was
working with the government
on this sort of stuff it doesn't matter
that's not the goal the goal is not
to stop misinformation the goal is to
exercise dramatic
top-down control over all information
that the left does not like
they're not again they're not hiding the
ball in this this is not some sort of
giant conspiracy they're they're saying
it directly out in the open
facebook by the way said quote the fact
that more than 2 billion people have
viewed authoritative information about
covet 19 and vaccines on facebook which
is more than any other place on the
internet
more than 3.3 million americans have
also used our vaccine finder tool to
find out where and how to get a vaccine
the facts show facebook is helping save
lives period that's true
that's actively true but it doesn't
matter and the goal is broader than this
it is not about covid
it is not about vaccines the goal is
much broader than this
hey here's the surgeon general of the
united states saying that social media
needs to be doing more again in social
media's fault it's not your own
garbage positioning on the vaccine it's
not your own vacillation and
flip-flopping
on the vaccine it's not your failures to
roll this thing out
properly it's not that it's not the fact
that the the federal government withdrew
the johnson and johnson vaccine from the
market
after six cases of a of a rare blood
clotting disorder after seven million
it's not any of that it must be social
media it's always and forever
agenda uber alice the only thing that
matters is top down control here's the
surgeon general of the united states
forwarding that
we saw misinformation flowing around
kovic 19 from the beginning
and we've raised those concerns to these
companies and
i've spoken about my concerns about
misinformation publicly
numerous times over the last many months
my concern is that we're not seeing
nearly enough progress here
and that's one of the reasons i issue
this advisory it's not entirely about
the tech companies
i issue this advisory to call the entire
country to action
recognizing their steps all of us can
take technology companies have an
important role particularly when it
comes to being transparent with the
public about how much misinformation is
flowing on their sites
okay and then the grey and saints did dr
fouchy he goes even further so the great
and sainted dr fauci the greatest doctor
in america after dr jill biden
he goes on cnn with jim acosta and
ladies find you a gentleman who loves
you like jim acosta loves jim acosta and
he informs people
that if there had been social media
during the eradication of smallpox and
polio
then there would they never would have
been eradicated now as we'll talk about
in just one second that's not true
i mean it's just factually untrue but
here is uh dr fauci spouting on truth
that's okay he's allowed
if you look at the extraordinary
historic success
in eradicating smallpox and eliminating
polio from most of the world and we're
on the brink
of eradicating polio if we had had the
pushback
for vaccines the way we're seeing on
certain media
i don't think it would have been
possible at all to not only eradicate
smallpox we probably would still
have smallpox and we probably would
still have polio in this country
if we had the kind of false information
that's being spread now
okay so i'll explain why this is
completely false okay a couple of
reasons one
smallpox is a disease that kills about
30 of the people who get it
if covered we're calling 30 of the
people who get it do you think there
would be any vaccine residency
the answer is pretty clearly no right
smallpox wiped out like one third of the
continent
of europe over the course of the dark
ages right like
this notion that smallpox people would
have been like oh man i'm so vaccinated
and hesitant it's pretty this vaccine is
probably more dangerous
than the smallpox you know how dangerous
smallpox was smallpox was so dangerous
that it allowed
for the first actual vaccination process
to take place because think about how
crazy this is the way they used to
create vaccines
is they would literally take the blood
from a person who had had smallpox and
then they would inject it in another
person in the hope that the antibodies
would transfer
right they would take the small pox from
one person and give it to another person
right
and hope the body would fight off the
weaker strain and people did this
voluntarily
you can by the way if you if you want to
actually see it in action
then you watch the hbo series john adams
right where people were doing the first
inoculations
as early as like the the late 18th
century early
19th century people were willing to do
that because smallpox was so dangerous
if covet was dangerous to smallpox i
promise you vaccine hesitancy would be a
lot lower you know how i know this
because look at the vaccine rates among
people who are over age 65
right people over age 65 have vacced up
at like a 90
rate why because that's where the most
of the danger from covet lives right
okay so this notion that it's about
social media as opposed to risk
assessment by individuals
is completely wrong now again my
assessment is that if you are
above the age of 21 you have a better
shot of dying from covid than you do of
having a serious effect from the vaccine
right so you should go get the vaccine
and for people who are 12 to 18 it seems
like that is also true it is not clear
that it's true for kids right so that's
the best information
about the vaccine at this time however
people can do their own risk assessments
on this sort of thing particularly since
the mrna vaccine is so unbelievably
effective
now esta polio it's kind of amazing that
we've forgotten this but the first
vaccine rollout for polio was a complete
battery
it was rolled out originally in 1955
there's a great piece over
at theconversation.com called
the great polio vaccine mess and the
lessons it holds about federal
coordination for today's covenant
vaccination effort by a guy named bert
specter who's an associate professor of
international business and strategy
at the dmr mckim school of business in
northeastern university
he points out that immediately following
the government licensing of the stock
vaccine
the national foundation for infantile
paralysis contracted with private drug
companies for about 9 million
worth of vaccine about 90 of the stock
they plan to provide it free
to the country's first and second
graders but just two weeks after the
first doses were administered the public
health service reported
six inoculated children had come down
with polio and the number of such
incidents grew
because it turned out there'd been a
battery a lab had actually not released
weakened polio strains in order to
generate immunity they'd actually
released
una basically adulterated doses of the
vaccine that included
polio so kids were actually being given
polio in the original
iteration of the vaccine rollout or at
least a certain percentage war
says this professor after considerable
fumbling and outright denial surgeon
general leonard steele pulled all
tainted vaccine off the market then less
than a month after the initial
inoculations
the u.s shut down distribution entirely
it was not until the introduction of a
new polio vaccine in 1960
created by albert sabin the public trust
return so it took five years
so was that because of social media or
what are you also going to blame social
media for that so again
it is not about preventing people from
getting bad information about vaccines
so much as it is about exercising
top-down
control that's really what it's about
because
the the biden administration has they
make no bones about this there's just
they're just sources they don't want to
see disseminate information
i'm very much against vaccine
misinformation
and if you post something that is
overtly false then it should come down
but if you are posting stuff that is
arguable if you are posting stuff
that is that is based in in theoretical
discussion
if you are posting theories about covet
lab leagues why would i possibly trust
this government to determine what is
true and what is false
about all of this stuff i mean the same
people who are now
declaring that they ought to be the
single greatest verifiers of information
we're providing misinformation about the
vaccine from the beginning we've got
kamala harris now
on board with all this it was kamala
harris who way back when was saying you
shouldn't get the vaccine if it was
developed under the trump administration
here is kamala harris not all that long
ago this was during the campaign
let's just say there's a vaccine that is
approved and even distributed before the
election
would you get it well i think that's
going to be an issue for all of us
um i will say that i would not
trust donald trump and it would have to
be
a credible source of information that
talks about the
um the efficacy and the and the
reliability
of whatever he's talking about i will
not take his word for it he wants us to
inject bleach no i will not take his
word
by the way joe biden was saying the
exact same thing joe biden was saying
you know any process that's done under
trump i'm not sure i trust that process
americans have had to endure president
trump's incompetence and dishonesty
when it comes to testing and personal
protective equipment
we can't afford to repeat those fiascos
when it comes to a vaccine
when it occurs the stakes are too high
american families have already suffered
and sacrificed
too much so let me be clear
i trust vaccines i trust
scientists but i don't trust donald
trump
okay so that was that who's who's
preventing misinformation at that point
who and yet these are the people who say
they should be in charge of
all informational distribution and again
it's not just about covid it's not i'll
get to that in just one second it is not
just about covid it is about control of
all the information you see
this is the goal we'll get to that in
one second first let's talk about
leading
a healthier life a healthier life
doesn't mean sticking to someone else's
strict rules it means having more
knowledge to build smarter more
sustainable habits
noom's cognitive behavioral approach
focuses on why instead of what
to help you change your relationship
with food everybody's journey looks
different noom customizes a program for
you based on your personal goals you may
have noticed i'm looking a lot more
svelted these days that's because
i used new myself it is an excellent way
to change your eating and exercise
habits 80 percent of newm users finish
the program over 60 percent have stuck
with their goals for at least a year
with noom taking care of your health is
empowering instead of stress inducing
no need to fear ruining the whole
program with one day off noon will help
you get back on track
all you need is 10 minutes a day noon
fits into your life on your terms
no grueling early mornings or huge
chunks out of your day
start building better habits for
healthier long-term results sign up
for your trial at noom.com shapiro that
is
n-o-o-m.com shapiro i've used new my
wife is a big recommender of noom my
parents have started using them it is an
excellent way to change your daily
habits so you lose weight so you feel
healthier that's what nume is all about
sign up your trial with noom.com today
alrighty we're going to get to
the actual broader goal here which again
has nothing to do with covet and
everything to do with control
of informational dissemination on a
broad level first let me remind you
again my newest book the authoritarian
moment is coming on sale next tuesday
july 27th it is the most important book
of the day
it is it goes through how all of our
institutions have been weaponized
against your freedoms how they have been
weaponized in order to
cast you out into the cornfield and more
importantly
how we take back these institutions
which we must because if we do not
if we do not neutralize institutions
they become weapons of the left the
country is basically finished as you're
going to read there's a lot happening
right now i predicted in this book
everything that's going on right now
with the crackdown on social media
everything from that to the perversion
of our education system
it's all talked about in the book you'll
want to pick up your copy of the
authoritarian moment right now to get a
sense of what's to come
and how we can stop it head on over to
dailywire.com ben order your signed copy
today i truly think it's an important
book
like very important because again no
matter what industry you work in no
matter what industries you come into
contact with they're being re-normalized
and weaponized by an active
motivated authoritarian left i'll be
doing a live stream book signing event
next tuesday the 27th pre-order your
signed copy today
when you do you'll be asked to type in a
question at checkout then catch
tuesday's live signing to see if i
answer your question and watch me sign
your book get your copy at dailywire.com
ben
right now now the legacy media it wreaks
a propaganda shameless virtue signaling
blatantly disregarding the truth at
every turn
it's a complete breach of america's
trust it's no wonder americans have lost
faith in those who are supposed to keep
them informed
at the same time those news outlets
dominate the stream of information
reaching the american public
podcasting is no exception that is why
we are bringing you something brand new
it's called morning wire it's a daily
news show it values your time
and the truth brought to you by daily
wire editor and chief john bickley and
co-host georgia howe
morningwire will wake you up with the
latest developments in politics sports
culture education all with a heavy
emphasis
on fact above all because they don't
care about your feelings it is available
today
like today you can get all your news
here it's great it's available today
subscribe right now
to morning wire on apple podcast spotify
everywhere you listen to podcasts so you
don't
miss a beat if you like what you hear
leave a five star review help point
fellow americans in the direction of
truth
thanks for listening go check it out
morning wire right now you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show
in the nation
[Music]
i should just point out here that on a
data level when people say that facebook
is responsible for vaccine hesitancy
it's a lie it's just not true
okay and the notion that it is
right-wing vaccine hesitancy that's
causing
the large-scale unvaccination that's
happening in the country right now
here's the racial breakdown on
vaccination in the united states
asian americans are vaccinated at a 62
percent rate white americans are
vaccinated at a 47
rate hispanic americans are vaccinated
at a 39
rate black americans are vaccinated at a
rate is that because black and hispanic
americans are in huge numbers huge
unprecedented numbers watching tucker
carlson's show
or because they are accessing bad
vaccine information via facebook is that
really what's going on here
is it because of evil right-wing
dissemination of information
that must be cracked down upon by the
biden administration
i have an article right here from the
new york post state data shows one
third of new york hospital workers are
unvaccinated who's
who's responsible for that maybe we need
to crack down on misinformation from the
new york state government because
obviously they're doing something wrong
one third of all healthcare workers
in new york are still unvaccinated
in new york city which was like the
epicenter of this thing
more than nine months into the campaign
to inoculate medical workers and all new
yorkers against the killer bug nearly a
third of staffers at big apple hospitals
are still unvaccinated
those figures were compiled by the state
health department they show nearly 40
percent
of hospital staff across three boroughs
have either refused or have not received
their coveted 19 at vaccines
even in hospital heavy manhattan only 76
percent of workers were vaccinated
matching the statewide average that
means one in four medical staffers are
still
unvaccinated well clearly i mean this is
like the hotbed of right-wing activity
that we've been told is responsible for
the vast unvaccination
of the american public okay so what is
this really about
what this is really about the game is
given away by karis wisher who's been
pushing for this crap
forever harris wisher is one of the
worst columnists in america
she writes for the new york times and
her sole goal for the past several years
has been to
push prod or beat the living hell out of
facebook into doing what she wants them
to do
not just with regard to vaccines
vaccines are just her latest thing
but with regard to everything she has a
piece today titled they're killing
people
biden isn't quite right but he's not
wrong
quote it was a stunning thing to say
even if it is in many ways true
they're killing people president biden
said loudly enough to be heard under the
roar of his marine one helicopter
idling on the south lawn of the white
house on friday he was not talking about
terrorists or leaders of rogue nations
or even gun manufacturers
he was talking silicon valley tech
moguls most specifically people like
mark zuckerberg and cheryl sandberg the
top two leaders of facebook and their
platform's role
in allowing dangerous misinformation
about the coven 19 vaccines to spread
far and wide the only pandemic we have
is among the unvaccinated they're
killing people he said
says the new york times this message has
clearly been coordinated
as tensions have increased between the
biden administration and facebook
particularly
that had been signaled earlier in the
week in a much less stark way by jen
saki
biden's press secretary and surgeon
general vivek murthy saki pointed to a
public health crisis as a reason to
pressure social media companies which
also face difficulty trying to balance
concerns about protecting speech with
the danger of some misinformation
in an interview with me two weeks ago
says karis wisher biden's chief of staff
ron klain
also seemed to be laying the groundwork
for putting the blame on facebook for
the administration not reaching its
promised goal of 70
by july 4th as you might imagine
facebook did not agree
with the characterization the truth says
kara swisher is that facebook serves as
a gateway to both
presenting clearly solid information
about covet as well as a place where an
enormous flood of lies about it has
overwhelmed the same zone and for a much
longer time
back in may of last year for example as
noted in the new york times there was
pandemic a 26 minute video alleging
a secret group of powerful people were
using the virus and the upcoming
vaccines to make money
and consolidate control over the world
now here's the question if plandemic had
been outright banned by facebook and
twitter and youtube right from the
beginning
what would have happened the filmmakers
would have claimed they were being
suppressed
and do you think all the people who were
ready to watch pandemic were suddenly
going to turn into
pro vaccine advocates i have serious
doubts about that
here is kara swisher's conclusion and
this gives away the game
she says in this era the media driver's
seat is controlled here and worldwide by
facebook youtube and twitter which makes
them
an easy target for the biden
administration while one could just as
easily cast aspersions at the blatantly
false jeremiah ads on fox news
the reality is that it's you can't blame
individuals either
you can't resist social media
juggernauts attempting to stop
falsehoods by claiming to offer good
information
is like using a single sandbag to hold
back an impossibly fetid ocean
it's like that when it comes to a range
of once anodyne
now divisive issues says karis wisher
from election integrity to critical race
theory
to whatever keeping this country in a
constant state of twitchy confusion
wherever it came from it remains more
even more pressing especially now
lies travel much faster thanks to
facebook cara swisher that one sentence
is the whole ball game the whole ball
game
it's not about covid it's about all the
issues
social media is bad because it allows
you to access information tara swisher
does not want you to see
and so it must be cracked down upon and
the press will push for it and the
democrats will push for it and now the
white house will push forward this is
authoritarian
nonsense and you should be afraid of it
if you're a freedom-loving human being
by the way it's now getting quite
personal okay the fact is that npr a
taxpayer-funded entity
has a piece deliberately now doing this
so they can't claim that we are
generating misinformation at daily wire
about the code of vaccine because we are
not
again i may be the most pro-vaccine host
on the right hey my site does not print
covered misinformation we don't do it
okay we've been pretty hawkish about
cobit i'm in favor of people being able
to make their own risk assessments
based on the proper available
information much of which was suppressed
by the biden administration about for
example the efficacy of the vaccines in
the early days when dr fauci was lying
and telling you
that wearing a mask was was completely
necessary even if you were vaccinated
and then later he he reversed himself of
course okay so
npr is now pushing basically the npr's
going the rest of the way so npr a
taxpayer-funded entity is now pressuring
facebook to suppress
daily wire and my facebook page
especially and directly
why not because we are presenting this
information but because we are
conservative
they're openly saying it it's right
there okay quote outrage as a business
model
how ben shapiro is using facebook to
build an empire now we've made no secret
of the fact
that facebook as a powerful social media
outlet is one of the places
where we push for traffic just as we do
on instagram just as we do on youtube
just as we do on twitter just like every
company does on all of the major social
media outlets
but it's bad that we're succeeding
according to npr that's the problem
and that must be stopped this is a case
that's now being astro turfed
by a wide variety of sources who have
decided that facebook is deeply
embarrassed of the fact they might
they're suppressing information that we
are successful we're not suppressing
information that we're successful on
facebook or anywhere else
thank god a lot of people read our site
thank god a lot of people listen to the
show and they have every
right to do so and did it ever occur to
npr and the journalists are so all fire
concerned
about people viewing our content that
they are acting like authoritarian
idiots
did it ever occur to them that i have
never said that npr
should be foreclosed the ability to
disseminate information
i think we should cut out its funding i
don't see why i ought to pay for the
federal government to attack my site
that seems weird i don't see why
conservatives across the land
tens of millions of whom access our
content every month multiple times
i don't see why exactly they should be
funding npr to attack the outlets they
actually like to to breed and watch
so npr is this piece it's not about
covered misinformation it's about social
media should shut down daily wear
because daily wire is daily wire
in 2021 ben shapiro rules facebook the
conservative podcast hosts an author's
personal facebook page has more
followers than the washington post
and he drives an engagement machine
unparalleled by anything else on the
world's biggest social networking site
an npr analysis of social media data
found that over the past year
stories published by the site shapiro
founded the daily wire received more
likes
shares and comments on facebook than any
other news publisher by a wide margin
even legacy news organizations that have
broken major stories or produced
groundbreaking investigative work don't
come anywhere close
oh are we hurting your feelings are we
hurting your feelings with the fact
people like clicking on our headlines
is it hurtful to you that the new york
times with its
with with honestly like the most
unreadable headlines in the news
business aren't getting clicked upon
maybe you should write readable
headlines that people give a crap about
maybe you should do that
or maybe the reason people are clicking
on our site as opposed
to the vast panoply of left-wing sites
is because there are many many left-wing
sites in like two
conservative sites maybe that's the
reason
or maybe the reason is because they
don't trust you
and your attempt to suppress information
and so they click on us more because
they don't trust you and they shouldn't
trust you
because you're a bunch of overtly well i
should say covertly partisan it's i mean
it's clear
you're trying to play this game where we
pretend like we don't see your biases
absurd
here's the more of npr dailywire
articles with headlines like quote book
review
proof that wokeness is projectioned by
nervous racist white women who can't
talk to minorities without elaborate
codes regularly garner tens of thousands
of shares for the site
and shapiro is turning that facebook
reach into a rapidly expanding
cost-efficient media empire
one that experts worry may be furthering
polarization in the u.s
oh my god conservatives exist
polarization see this is it's so funny
this is how the left views polarization
polarization is usually when people
unfairly attack
one another and tell lies about each
other say like when the president of the
united states says you're a jim crow
segregationist because you like voter id
like that would be furthering
polarization but here's the thing for
the media
for the left their monopoly prevents
polarization
because you see there's no other point
of view if it is unipolar
there is no polarization if there is
only one pole there can be
no polarization you see it's amazing if
there's a monopoly on information and
everyone agrees with each other there's
no polarization inside the monopoly but
the moment
daily wire exists polarization it must
be stopped shut down daily wire
says npr again a tax payer funded entity
quote there's a demand
among certain subjects of the public for
outraged politics said jamie settle the
director of the social networks and
political psychology lab
at the college of william and mary in
virginia this happens on both the left
and right but the people who do this on
the right have just found a lot more
successful ways of doing
havely halfway because joe biden won 80
million votes on the basis
that everyone who had disagreed with him
was a threat to democracy and he's still
saying it
the daily wire did not respond to
interview requests from npr for this
story yeah you know why because
that's why you think i don't know your
agenda before you start this crap
we know your agenda the moment you email
us as part of an astroturf effort
to force facebook into stopping the
dissemination of our website we know
exactly what you're doing everyone can
see what you're doing
the world's worst magicians don't even
misdirect with this hand you're just
doing the trick right here
says npr the site produces very little
original reporting our investigative
reporting team would beg to differ
people like
luke rosiak who have been breaking
stories from loudoun county but instead
mostly repackages journalism from
traditional news organizations with the
conservatives land
that alone wouldn't be newsworthy the
the circle of life online means
information
is written and rewritten in a seemingly
infinite loop but
the daily wire has turned anger into an
art form and recycled content into a
business model
wait no so so now the problem isn't that
we're lying and it's not that we're
doing anything different from anybody
else it's that we're good at it
oops i'm so sorry are we hurting your
feelings
here oh poor npr oh a little ball
so sad got the world's tiniest violin in
may
the daily wire generated more facebook
engagement on its articles than the new
york times the washington post nbc news
and cnn combined yeah you know why
because we're good at our jobs and
because you guys kind of suck
okay that's the reality people don't
like your content and so they click on
the opposite content by the way if you
think the new york times the washington
post nbc news and cnn are having
media troubles in terms of like people
clicking on their site
this is a complete misread i promise you
that all of the sites that you just
mentioned
have bigger traffic than we do overall
other conservative outlets like the
blaze breitbart news in the western
journal that publish
aggregated and opinion content aimed at
invoking outrage have also generally
been more successful at generating
engagement than legacy news outlets over
the past year
the success of those allots on facebook
may also undermine conservatives off
repeated claims that social media
networks have an anti-conservative bias
okay well i mean i can show you exactly
when and where the spigots get turned
off on our traffic because we watch it
every single day
so yeah no tracking the amounts of
engagement a poster outlet gets on
facebook
is not the same thing as tracking the
number of people the content actually
reaches through the platform
in october facebook released data
showing that the sort of conservative
clickbait that performs well in
engagement metrics was not actually
being seen by as many people
as articles from the more mainstream
news outlets
okay so in other words they're now
complaining that people click
on our headlines but don't read through
to the story so they're basically now
admitting that they
still get more traffic than we do but
we're still bad because we exist
daily wire is clearly successful this is
well thanks we appreciate it
the company is growing and profitable
according to ceo jeremy boring who told
axios earlier this year the company
plans to expand more into entertainment
and further build out the daily wires
smartphone app
while other publications have seen their
engagement numbers for facebook fall off
this year the daily wire has stayed
fairly constant according to npr's
analysis
i'm depressed by it but i'm not that
surprised said settle this has
everything to do with the psychology of
news consumers and the broader issues
with polarization in american culture
see again
the problem is polarization is caused by
us existing this this
article is just we exist daily aware
exists and people read it
polarization maybe it's polarizing that
you want to shut us down
maybe that's the polarizing aspect of
american politics these days again for
the 1000th time
i have not called for npr's
informational dis
informational distribution to be shut
down i've done so with regard to no
other media outlet but i'm noticing a
lot of people from these media outlets
want me shut down
weird how that works the articles the
daily wear publishes don't normally
include falsehoods
and the site says it's committed to
truthful accurate and ethical reporting
but as settle explains by only covering
specific stories that bolster the
conservative agenda
like negative stories about socialist
countries and polarizing stories about
race and sexuality issues
and only including certain facts readers
still come away from the daily wires
content with the impression republican
politicians can do little wrong and
cancel culture is among the nation's
greatest threats so in other words
again is npr saying you're a
conservative so you're bad they admit
that we are not saying anything false
they're just angry that we're
conservative
by the way the new york times only
covers specific stories that bolster
their narrative
they only tell you specific facts that
bolster their narrative
in the same way we do the differences
we're honest and they're liars they'll
tell you they're objective and we'll
we're conservative get over it
an npr review of stories on the daily
wire about the cove 19 pandemic over the
past few months found numerous stories
about potential side effects from covet
but none
that portrayed the scientifically
demonstrated efficacy of the vaccines or
which focused explicitly on the
hesitancy that has slowed the us
rollout um wait hold up a second
you're saying that we are anti-facts are
you insane
are you crazy listen to a single moment
of this show
okay the site routinely talks about the
efficacy of the vaccines
we do this all the time
often the site's headlines seem like a
conglomeration of conservative abuzz
words this is reporting from npr your
taxpayer-funded entity
medical experts urges we must make life
hard for unvaccinated test them twice
weekly there's nothing false about that
headline
they tend not to provide much context
for the information they're providing
said settle
if you've stripped away enough context
any piece of truth can become a piece of
misinformation
there it is right there right everything
is misinformation because we don't like
how you are telling it
it's true but we don't like it it's
misinformation
this piece is a master class in the kind
of suppression the left wishes to use in
social media to shut down your ability
to access information
this authoritarian bull
pushed by your taxpayer dollars
apparently
it's just incredible so we're bad
we should we should be shut out they say
in the years since he left breitbart
news shapiro has carved out a rare niche
within the conservative media world
the graduate of harvard law school taps
into many of the same culture war themes
that former president donald trump
played into
while also disagreeing with trump a feat
he's managed without becoming a target
of the former president's ire shapiro
has publicly denounced the alt-right and
other people in trump's orbit like steve
bannon
as well as the conspiracy theory trump
is the rightful winner of the 2020
election
but in the same column i wrote after the
violence on january 6th
last week the capital was breached by a
group of french trump supporters who had
bought into a series of lies but in the
same column he quickly turned his
attention back to democrats
and their support of the nationwide
black lives matter protest last year
which many conservatives have falsely
sought to paint broadly as riots
he's been widely condemned for anti-lgbt
comments
oh my god wow so again i'm conservative
this means i'm bad
he's he's he's just i'm terrible and
then they quote a bunch of people who
don't like me
incredible really well done here so
basically the idea here is we should not
exist because we're good at our jobs
that's the entire article the entire
article is from npr dailywear should not
exist
and we're misinformation because they
disagree they're coming for your
information
they're coming for the outlets you like
they're coming to suppress them
this is one more reason why you should
support every outlet
that you like come subscribe at daily
wire because they're going to come after
us they're going to try and z platform
us it's something they are overtly
making clear
they want to do right now okay so come
subscribe over at daily wire right now
also pick up a copy of my book all about
all of this and do it for other people
too
if you like the blaze go subscribe at
the blaze if you like fox nation go
subscribe at fox nation
seriously you need to subscribe to the
services you like because the left is
going to try to take them away they're
going to try to take neutral service
providers like facebook and destroy them
if they don't become overtools of the
left
that's the goal it's despicable it's
authoritarian it's polarizing it's going
to destroy the country
they are responsible for the
polarization they are responsible
for tearing all of this apart they are
responsible for shutting down
any sort of rational realistic or decent
debate on these issues
and then they proclaim that they're in
favor of american unity and truth
yep alrighty we'll be back here later
today with much much more in the
meantime go check out the michael
knowles show
today he discusses the story of a porn
star showing up to a conservative
student summit you can hear more details
about that story over on michael's show
that's available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pawel wydowsky
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barber the show is
edited by adam sci events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant jessica crans the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021 the biden
white house is calling on big tech to
censor
conservatives for spreading
misinformation online a porn star shows
up to a conservative student summit that
i happen to be at right now
and in los angeles the officials are
calling on a new
mask mandate even for people who have
already been vaccinated with the vaccine
that's so effective
that you still need that filthy cloth
over your face check it out on the
michael knowles show